on this Bittersweet day the father of
Kaylee Gonzalez Steve Gonzalez Steve
thank you so much for making the time to
be with us today just your first
reaction to the news that a suspect has
been arrested
uh to me uh in my family it feels like
the first story that we've had in seven
days because it really is
um you know you can't even smile
when you have this over your head and uh
feels like a little bit of weight has
been believed in things are on the right
track and we're moving in the right
direction you know was there anything in
the press conference that the police
just gave this afternoon that was not
said to you as a parent in the situation
did they leave something out that you
wish the public knew about
foreign
the whole struggle of communication and
everything has gotten better every step
of the way
um I want to commend those police
officers and everything that they've
done because it has been very difficult
to uh work with all the media especially
me being so vocal I think it's gotten
better and I I really appreciate that
they've made some adjustments for our
family and uh We've noticed those things
Steve I I was telling our colleagues
that there has been a different tone
from you today as we got this good news
that they did indeed catch the suspect
when we were talking earlier today one
of the things that stuck out to you was
this guy was not from Moscow he was an
outsider
yes the community is real in Idaho and
Idaho made a stance and I wanted to be a
part of that to where we said hey this
is not our new normal we're not going to
allow this messaging to be our new
normal and we're going to put our foot
down and we're going to pull in every
resource that we can we have nothing to
hide if we have to pull in forces
because we're close to a location that
you know jurisdictions are are there
we're still going to uh come together
and unify for this and uh I really feel
like that's what happened I mean there
was some forces that pulled us apart but
in the end we all we all became together
and we have a celebration of life today
and we actually have hope that we have
somebody in custody that is a person
of interest and of course he's innocent
until proven guilty but that's a lot
better off than we were you know 48
hours ago Steve why was it important
today for you to have that memorial
service for not only Kaylee but from
Maddie with this being the day that it
is why did you guys decide to
you're going to push through and you're
going to have this serve this
celebration of life for your daughters
it was important for us to
have this person of interest in custody
so they weren't possibly in that
audience because we made it open and we
knew we made ourselves vulnerable like
that we didn't want somebody to be
taking advantage of that and feeding off
that or we definitely don't want to feed
somebody
who's you know a predator to our
environment so it's nice that we have
this closure
um there's a lot of prayers going across
America
Steve it's Kennedy um everyone here at
Fox uh we pray for you and we hope that
God continues to sustain all of your
families uh through this unspeakable
tragedy I know that you have done so
much work and you have been so vocal and
you have done so much investigation and
I'm just wondering had you heard the
name Brian coburger before today
no uh we had not that's just completely
honest um everything was kept under the
Rocks the investigation did uh
everything they could do keep this uh
away from the public to keep the jury
uncainted do everything by the book and
I believe they've done an amazing job of
that
Steve it's Jimmy Fela uh as a parent I
can't imagine what you're going through
uh but one of the things we have uh
found heartening uh with a tragedy as
awful as this is how a tight Community
like the one in Moscow has been pulled
tighter uh by the love they had for your
daughter can you speak to the sense of I
don't know maybe relief is there some
type of emotional upward Mobility today
given the capture of this dirtbag
yeah I mean it is it felt like we were
all in this together and I feel like
everybody did something that was
uncomfortable they uh took photos they
submitted information they took time
and um in the end I hope when the
story's all set and told that we
actually do find out that some of these
tips and leads from the community were
critical and I would not be surprised if
that's you know this is going to be a
community based Justice that uh was
exercised in this whole process
Steve brother uh you may have been so
strong and I'm so glad that they caught
this guy before the new year thank you
so much for stepping away from the
memorial service and spending some time
with our audience thank you sir thank
you Steve very much for taking the time
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else